in the future we're going to have this
concept of hybrid teams and a hybrid
team will have humans who now do really
high value work
because they're not doing the admin the
manually repetitive but they're also not
having to deal with some of the
unpredictability that that customers or
managers our employees always bring to
the party
see what's an orchestrate
changing the concepts of the future of
work
what I find interesting is that when you
talk about the future of work and and
the hybrid Workforce
ninety percent of what you're reading
research is about the where work gets
done you know is it are people going to
be in the office once a month once a
week three days a week full time and
every company has different kind of
views on that
I think that's a wrong question to ask
around digital workers
digital workers will change the who gets
work done and the way that actually work
itself gets done
so the how and the who are what digital
workers will change the conversation
towards when it comes to a hybrid
Workforce not necessarily the where the
really exciting bit is the fact that
you're going to have teams now in every
single part of HR and ultimately every
part of most functions within IBM that
are truly hybrid that have people doing
higher value work and have orchestrate
doing the lower mid value work we've
already seen in HR jobs like chatbot
content manager conversation Specialists
data scientist garage
and design thinking leads you know
irresistible offering reviews and and ux
attack rules all of them are now coming
to IBM HR that we would never have
thought of two three years ago